how did how did your your parents handle
the shadow because I think that's the
that's the hardest thing to do right how
do you manage the shadow where a kid
your brother's a an actor as well and he
goes and does what he does and you guys
have a different temperament your
personalities in a different way than
his but he gives you love he gives you
respect you guys are a very loving very
United Family even though you have
differing opinions was there any moment
where they talked about your last name
and the concept of Shadow this is a
great question and this this really uh
touches on pretty like a pretty defining
aspect of just my entire life and my
entire story is that while my parents
did a great job in raising me and they
would raised me very consciously they're
great parents they're great people
um
they were not conscious of of that they
were conscious of what it's like to be
them but they were not conscious of what
it's like to be in the shadow of them
right and I think that and that's that's
nothing against them you know I mean
they're in their position they're
dealing with all sorts of factors being
in their position you know there you
can't see what you don't see right so
because that's an entirely different
position to be in the shadows what a
point right so you you know you don't
know what you don't know right so this
like this
the the like they were they weren't
necessarily capable of providing me they
they they provided me a lot of guidance
in raising me but they weren't capable
of providing me guidance in in these
areas of of me just trying to figure out
how to navigate these Waters of of being
in this shadow of this Fame and being on
the periphery of it but that had nothing
to do with me right it had nothing to do
with me I'm just a [ __ ] kid trying to
trying to um you know I know that I've
been dealt to some cards and I'm just
trying to figure out how to play them
and I have no [ __ ] idea how to do it
and I and I you know the only way I
learned is through you know [ __ ] up
is through playing them [ __ ] terribly
playing my hand terribly over and over
and over and over again right and that's
that's pretty much um
that that's kind of like my my story
right there
what leads me to today right was he on
the road a lot were they acting on the
road thing or not really it's not as
many road we my dad did work a lot but
we we traveled with him okay you know
really I never felt like oh my dad's not
around oh that's it that that never I
never felt that way like oh like my dad
didn't show up to my [ __ ] baseball
game like no none of that none of that
my parents were there they were always
there right it was just it it well my
struggle wasn't it wasn't in any lack of
you know my relationship with my parents
my struggle was my own struggle in
trying to navigate the Waters of the
world with this in this Shadow and on
this periphery of this this Fame this
huge focal point right that really had
nothing to do with me right it had
nothing to do with me but I was a proxy
of it right and this this is this is
where I go and this is the defining
story of my life right and trying to
navigate these Waters because the nature
of those Waters the nature of those
Waters is an entirely different Beast
than the nature of the waters when
you're you you're a focal point because
of your prestige that you've earned
right when you are a focal point and
you're a goat like you said for for the
work and your talent that you've earned
in navigating the Waters of the world as
that right that's an entirely different
entirely different scenario than
navigating the Waters of the world for
someone who's a proxy of that Prestige
and that focal point but it's just there
because they were born in it
not because they did anything to earn it
that that right so like my
the reason why I say that was a you know
struggle for me is because
I mean there there are so many paradoxes
you know it's just it's just like
mind-boggling
paradoxes
is the nature of what I'm talking about
what I mean by that is
this is the ultimate Paradox right is
that
my my entire life people have always
thought when okay I walk into a room
okay
you know a 14 year old chat walks in 12
year old Chet walks into a room okay not
me now I'm like a public figure and
people know me for me
but take it back before them before
anyone knew me
okay 14 year old Chet walks into a room
no one knows anything about me
all they know is that I'm Tom hanks's
son yeah there's going to be immediate
assumptions okay
the Assumption right
the number one assumption
that people make
is number one I must live the life of
like Richie Rich spoiled rich kid
spoiled rich brat number two the
assumption is I think that I'm better
than everyone in the room
that I feel that I that I truly think
that I'm superior to every single person
in that room you're a 14 year old kid
with a Target on his back before you
even step in the room before I even step
in the room and the truth was
those both of those things couldn't have
been farther from the truth I wasn't
spoiled I was blessed I was privileged
right but I wasn't spoiled there's a big
difference
I was privileged because I got to go to
I got you know I got to go to good
schools I got a great education I had a
loving family
I didn't have to I didn't have to worry
I had to you know I lived in and I had
to you know travel and do cool [ __ ]
right but I wasn't spoiled it wasn't
like here's here's your black card go
run crazy do whatever you want
you know what I'm saying here's a
freaking you know Bentley for your 16th
birthday okay you know what I mean none
of that none of that what's the most
expensive gift you ever got just so
people know did you ever get like a
brand new
uh
BMW M5 M3 when I turned 16 my first car
was a was a used uh PT Cruiser a 2002 PT
Cruiser I remember the PT Cruiser okay
yeah because and I was thankful to have
that car by the way I assumed this was I
was thankful to have that car because
otherwise I would have to ride the
school bus okay so it wasn't like I was
stoked on the PT Cruiser can you show
what a PT Cruiser looks like because I
know exactly what this looks like I like
the PT Cruiser at the time killing the
game going back to it when you're going
through that by the way yeah that's a PT
Cruiser
I'm killing the game chat so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]